I actually think that there's a may I'm
just optimistic but a surprising
potential for agreement here so far in
the room I should parenthetically say
that Peter Singer was invited but he has
a moral reason for not traveling on
weekends that reduces to loyalty to his
family that I tried to I was thinking of
using a utilitarian counter argument but
you know as Massimo says whether it's
science or morality or whatever we have
some axioms we have some assumptions and
then we get off the ground but I think
that what Steve is getting at correctly
is that they're the kinds of axioms you
need to get morality off the ground the
kinds of possibilities are very very
different than the kinds of axioms you
would need to get science off the ground
I mean science really has these very
thin methodological axioms about you
know the world is not trying to trick us
when we collect data well yes so that's
where I would actually disagree but I
think well it effectively does but the
kinds of axioms you postulate or
whatever to get morality going are
closer to the scientific theories that
we have when we possibly you know the
triggers equation is writer that
Einstein's equations right now we can go
ahead and test it in some way that's
what we need to sort of make predictions
and do things and the kinds of axioms
you need for morality just don't have
that testability or sort of verify
ability they do in terms of where
they're I mean you could make a rule
that there is no such thing as morality
there's a series of feelings that we
have that enable us to live harmoniously
in our society and in our world I think
that's where natural where animal
derived morality is continuous with
human morality for but but the but I
think we all we all seem to agree that
you know just because evolution has
given us some impulses some some
tendencies doesn't make them right in
the sense that we use the word right
there's a clear that living harmoniously
in our world is the test for that is
right but I would nevertheless agree
with Rebecca that we can applaud wheat
we do rather than universal postulates
that we all can sort of argue for on the
basis of reason or evidence we all have
something inside us that we recognize
our own personal version of morality and
it's not universal right it's different
and it comes from evolution and from
society as Don says and many other
things and I think what we seem to be
maybe moving toward is this idea that
the the job of morality is just very
different from the job of science
because we think all of these individual
very different tendencies that we have
and then we reason about them and that's
the sort of political kind of thing that
that Dan was pointing to and it's it's
it might be logical and rational and we
might hope I'm not nearly as pessimistic
as Steve you seem to be that we couldn't
take those inchoate vague tendencies we
have and think hard about them and turn
them into a logical set of postulates
that we could then move forward on and I
think that these at least some of the
progress of how we treat each other over
the last several hundred years is due to
people thinking about it you know I'm
sure that if you hold Thomas Jefferson
that slavery was bad he would say you
know yeah in some sense slavery is bad
but I have other you know moral things
that over overrule it for me and we
talked ourselves out of that and I think
that it's a very different kind of
process that we're going to go under
science and none of us seems to be
defending the idea that we will reduce
morality to science but I still think
that everything that people have said so
far is compatible with the idea that we
can capture morality in a in a
reasonable philosophical frame is that
and it relates to what you're saying as
well is that it's um there's a lot of
upheaval along the way and often
the victims or the people will want to
be let in to this nice Memorial Circle
have to have a case for themselves so
you know black people work in that case
two females organized animals can't
organize I can't advocate for themselves
and so you know that and I think that's
a very very big difference and why but
you know this thing doesn't happen
smooth like and it doesn't happen just
through reason for sure I do I do think
that the first step is reason and
there's a moral philosopher you know for
those who say that nothing ever happens
in philosophy
look at the history of moral progress
where are they the philosopher inserting
himself before work herself before I
mean even that who would have even said
concerning or herself anyway
you